[Musik]
an die Leute die beim letzten Jahr schon
voll vergessen diese komischen Maske
hier gegeben jetzt setzen wir diesen
Scheiß Ding ab kann ich nicht
wie was du musst sterben damit das Ding
abgeht dann töte mich mal kurz Leute wie
viel Schüsse brauche ich ich sage drei
ja schauen wir erstmal was Sie hier
alles so hatte was wir uns gönnen können
50 Brote dieser hat die denn 50 Brote
craftet wahrscheinlich von mir ich habe
das das letzte mal geklaut
Freunde von euch sollen äh Stories über
eure Schulzeit erzählen wie
beispielsweise haben die shady etc wir
waren mit keinem von denen in der Schule
wenn jemand unseren Geheimraum
[Musik]
oh
oh mein Gott nein das war ich gar nicht
natürlich
nicht ich schwöre das war ich nicht
fahren Alter
20 Sekunden später
ein schönes Foto von Dir machen vor der
Sonne vor siriushaus hat er sich gerade
gewünscht stell dich mal hier wo ich
stehe
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
guck mal wenn ich jetzt ein Stein
platziere ne Laser Luca der schwebt der
Stein schwebt ja nein
bei mir ist das direkt auf dem Holz
drauf wenn ich das Ding nehme und ich
sitze hier drauf bei mir ist der genau
hier drauf auf dem Holz
also der Holzblock wenn ich ihn
hinsetzen der ist genau auf dem Stein
warum sollte ich doch nicht da drauf
sein nein
der Block ist bei mir direkt drauf dann
ist das bei dir ein Grafikfehler dann
geh halt vom Server runter und dann geh
wieder drauf dann wirst es ja sehen
was machst du da schon wieder
[Musik]
was wird das Sandy
ich mache doch gar nichts ich guck doch
nur ein dickes Haus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es sieht schön aus hallo
[Musik]
nein ich bin angekettet
Platte Druckplatte in Sandras Haus ja
wäre eigentlich eine gute Idee
mal aufs Maul zu hauen kann man auch
Leute im Chat kann man sich
Fensterrahmen craften
irgendwie doch ich setze einen hin warte
wo soll der Fensterrahmen
ist drin
und hier
run
[Musik]
ich gehe ich bin weg mach's gut ich
glaube da komme ich gar nicht hoch komm
wir schauen uns das mal an was er da
vorne gebaut hat
warum nicht junge
ich komme doch nicht rein Rechtsklick
[Musik]
t
kurz ein paar Blöcke ab ja du bist
lustig wie soll ich denn hier hochkommen
oh nein oh mein Gott Sandy guck mal ich
bin Jesus Wasser laufen ich warte auf
dich dann können wir zusammen hochgehen
ich werde die so runterkicken wenn die
hier ist ne bist du gespannt ihr dass
man da anzuschauen
[Musik]
oh mein Gott ich bin so gespannt wie es
aussieht hä wie cool
für meine Haut schöner
sieht aber aus wie so ein pornozimmer
Bruder echt so nur Bett und Bilder ja ne
oh diese Materialien so schwarz rot gib
mir mal den heftigen Modus warum ich
will das eigentlich immer testen junge
oder nicht
[Musik]
kann aber dann machst Du nichts kaputt
okay
aber so etwas kaputt zu machen einfach
mutwillig und blöd nein nein nein ich
bin eigentlich dumm
okay was kann ich dann machen fliegen
die fliege ich denn alt Punkt F4
wie und dann alt und F4
ja passiert halten
[Musik]
wie oft kann man auf so etwas reinfallen
dann als offline nein hat hat sich durch
alte vielen PC runtergefahren oder was
sandra ist offline ich rufe die mal an
[Musik]
später
abgestürzt tut mir leid kann man nichts
machen
sorry dafür dass ich auch schon wieder
auf dem Server sehen wir gerade
hier bitte rein bei uns
am Stall geöffnet
wenn nicht an dem Stall an dem neuen
Stall ja die habe ich noch gar nicht
gesehen
die Schafe die sind doch drin warum
sollte ich die denn reindrücken da sind
zwei die passen nicht ganz rein optimal
rein ich will nicht dass die anderen
wieder rauslaufen ja so sehr gut
[Musik]
wie kann man so Spaß daran haben
irgendwelche computertiere zu verarschen
wenn euch der Stream gefallen hat dann
folgt mir gerne auf twitches kostenlos
dann erfahrt ihr wenn ich das nächste
Mal live bin oder halt einfach auf
Instagram vorbei schauen weil ich da
eigentlich immer Bescheid gebe wenn ich
live gehe danke schön für eure Support
ich habe euch ganz ganz doll lieb
[Musik]